okay so this next whoa my heart rate's
56 my watch working maybe I'm just so
calm so I assume this challenge was real
I have to botz Gambit and if I win the
offer was 100 gifted Subs so see what I
can try and do oh it's real
okay H I'm kind of nervous heart rate's
going to increase I have a feeling my
heart rate's going to be over 100 at
some point for this coming
game so what is what is the votes
gambits just scking the
queen I will match that 100 gift Subs if
you berserk win this
toury uh berserk winning the tournament
is not at all doable um even
mathematically
like
yeah I wish I could try
though
okay is it worth trying should I berserk
bz's
Gambit I wonder if my opponent's
watching
um what can I sack my queen for a bishop
at
least I think that's how opponent wants
to Queen trade that's
funny um well here's my bz Gambit I'm
threatening to take on C one hopefully
my opponent doesn't realize oops oh no
my
queen okay step one of the mission has
been
completed step one was the easy part
though step
two will be the more difficult
parts so to win from a position down a
queen
uh so the strategy when you're down a
queen or or when you make a mistake in
life is to first of all stop making
mistakes and to be grateful for what you
have a nice thing here is I can no
longer blunder my queen cuz I've already
blundered it unless I promote and make a
new Queen and then blender
that I mean the strategy is also to just
keep pieces on the board and hopefully
white will counter B's gabit
I'm playing some sort of like hippo
setup and G5 might
[Music]
come this is not going to be easy like
White's just being super solid here have
to play this sad move what to do but I'm
achieving my hippo at
least and I have something that my
opponent doesn't have
a dark
Bishop so maybe that will be useful
someday um Queens side Castle I
guess opponent's playing quickly
too which is kind of
[Music]
terrifying
okay I'm using my dark Bishop that was a
nice very juicy
Pawn very juicy Center
Pawn the problem though is I'm still
down a
queen
so but at least now I'm only down Queen
for Bishop and
[Music]
pawn it's about the small victories in
life I mean part of the strategy is just
to be patient and wait
for opponent to give me early Christmas
presents early Hanukkah
presents belated birthday
[Music]
presents yeah this night found a happy
place maybe I should have played this
first although this allows
this so
it's hard to actually make progress here
it's also hard to attack not having a
queen but I'm being grateful for my
minor
pieces maybe some
H5 could consider taking but I
definitely don't want to
trade let's play
this so both Knights have found happy
places and do I do I consume another
Pawn I can't tell if this is free food
or free
[Music]
poison looks like free
food I'm trying to smell it if it smells
like free food but it's not giving off
any
scent yeah cuz even though the Knight is
a little bit stuck
here okay now I can return here I can
also go this
way I mean I really don't want to
trade so let's go
back
and probably back
again yeah white really wants to
trade now I don't know if I can avoid
it I
take wait I have to
calculate um there
there actually a very annoying
move
take I have an
idea it's kind of risky
but maybe makes some sense I'm going
play
this cuz I really want to keep all the
minor pieces on the
board that was more scared of Queen F7
but that's not happening I guess now I I
have to trade off a minor
piece uh I guess it's a question do I
take the bishop
or the Knight probably want to take the
Knight cuz The Bishop's not so
great I still have all a pawns and all
two
Bishops
so it's bishop and two pawns for Queen
now I am down a couple
minutes my opponent's taking their
longest think of the game they're trying
to figure out how to trade more pieces
and they they've found a move maybe I
play
this cuz I don't mind if Rook
takes and Knight is returning to its
happy place
maybe C5
[Music]
coming the bishop saves itself could
take
here I'd rather play this
first that's a solid looking
setup trying to strengthen my grip on
the
position forgot about that
move I can
take
there I might as well
take I have two
Bishops I mean White's still objectively
better
but look at my my amazing
Bishops maybe maybe Pawn
F5 there's also this
move I think I got to go for
this so I'm not going to take the Rook
cuz the rook's
[Music]
pinned
there is this move to hit the
bishop it's actually a question here I
probably want to take with
Pawn there's some argument to take with
Rook okay maybe this move
move I feel spoiled for choice
now there
there let's go with
[Music]
this
goat what would a goat do in this
position thank you T
games Okay that was a welcome
surprise this is like
a a bz Gambit combined with
um sacrifice the
Rook okay I'm winning everything now I
went from being down a queen to now
being up a rook in three
pawns pawns are still smiling
too they try and be efficient with the
Checkmate actually the bishop controls
the square but okay no mercy
now I think madeen
almost
two calculating here here and then
checkmates but there is King
C4 oh this isn't
Checkmate where's my
checkmates there
there
me bring the king here I do have to be
careful not to
stalemates I want to play C4 checkmates
the most explosive
checkmates there we go okay that was a
risk that kind of paid off was risking a
lot of rating
there I think that was a nice controlled
game overall and despite hanging my
queen on move three
but
uh yeah I played the hippo
setup and I waited for the free material
took the
pawn took the other
Pawn opponent like actually found some
interesting idea to trade off the pieces
I think white could have taken the pawn
here even though it looks
risky I was going to
play Rook G8 also thank you thanks much
Gio
vco with the the 50 gifted really
appreciate the yeah the support and the
challenge another 50 gifted thank you
Gio vanco